I'm Laura Ingram thanks for joining us
this is the Ingram angle from Washington
tonight Tucker Carlson wow he's staying
up late are you kidding me yeah he's
gonna be here he's going to reveal what
he says is the single biggest change in
the way Americans may have to start
living but first
fake versus real that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
all right I decided on Friday night that
it's time to simplify things for
everyone you're all busy out there right
I'm going to simplify it
the Democrats are cratering and yet they
want everyone to believe that the
opposite is true as we approach the
midterms so for the past month all we've
heard about is Joe's supposed midterm
momentum that he's turned the corner
after a rocky summer of course the
opposite is actually true in fact
Reuters has Biden's approval rating at a
pathetic 39 even so Reuters spins it to
attack Trump somehow
you see how it works right Democrats
have zero accomplishments to point to
all they have are these lame attempts at
messaging their failures
but by every measure things are getting
worse in America but to Joe's goons that
just means that they have to throw more
dirt into the wind hoping you won't see
through the haze
but the angle don't worry is here to
help you differentiate the real issues
facing America from the fake ones that
the left is Raising
first Republicans are anti-democracy
it's clear which way the new Mega
Republicans are they're extreme and
democracy is really at stake we all saw
that day this Insurrection this mob that
came to attack our democracy our
democracy is at risk today
false pathetic come on look at Florida
they overhauled their entire voting
system after 2000 they made big changes
even after 2020 voters reason have
reasons now to actually trust the system
in Florida and the last time I checked
they actually count the votes on
Election night what a novel concept so
is democracy you know in Peril in
Florida no of course not
but their next fake is that extremism
and fascism are on the rise
you can look at any number of different
metrics um right-wing extremism is on
the rise there is no question that
extremism is on the rise in this country
and it poses a very real national
security threat this is ultra
nationalism this is fascism and uh it's
it's rising in America
false there is not a single person at
the White House at the DNC or at the
Washington Post who actually believes
that if Republicans win in 2022 or 2024
will no longer have elections okay that
it's fascism time in the United States
it's extremism run amok
and if you believe any of that you're
just a sucker
what about the next fake
that somehow conservative policies are
anti-women
and Republicans have been so scary in
what they're talking about taking away
women's rights to vote women's right to
choose women's rights in general are
clearly under attack throughout the
United States the ensuing attacks on
women's fundamental rights from elected
republicans in Congress
false really I mean women are going to
be locked in the kitchen wearing aprons
if the GOP wins
you think I'd be for that movement I
don't even cook well enough to do that
okay I'm not gonna be back in the
kitchen stupid
meanwhile in Democrats strongholds women
can't even go out jogging without
worrying about being assaulted
and how are soaring energy costs that
the Democrats have caused good for women
those voluntary blackouts in California
somehow that's good for women living
alone
oh and our high food prices oh those
must be great for women by their
calculus
the fact is strong women are on the rise
throughout the Republican party
including minority women
there's newly elected Texas
congresswoman Maya Flores also in Texas
there's Monica De La Cruz and Cassie
Garcia in Indiana Air Force vet Jennifer
Ruth green is vying for a house seat
that last saw a republican win in 1928
how about Michigan Tudor Dixon a
phenomenal candidate running to unseat
Governor Gretchen whitless Whitmer she's
down just eight points in the latest
average she should be the next governor
but remember
the left doesn't even consider any of
those women certainly women who believe
in populism or America First policies to
even be legitimate women at all
and of course there's the ultimate fake
that Republicans are racist at heart
the Republican party just won't reject
racism what the Republican party right
now stands for is white nationalist
racism as we head into the midterms
Republicans can be proud of racism
another vicious smear with zero evidence
in fact if there's racism on the rise in
the United States it's found in Liberal
policies that disproportionately harm
minorities
a Bank of America research report found
that inflation shock of 2021
disproportion proportionately affected
African Americans Hispanic and Latino
communities
and it's not just the economy day after
day Democrats are ignoring the
nightmarish problems facing Americans
which of course the left-wing policies
themselves created
like how government-run schools are
failing our kids
coveted lockdowns which Democrat Mayors
and governors embraced have led to
plummeting test scores and in Washington
D.C mayor Muriel Bowser's covet vax
mandate is going to prevent about 40
percent of black students from even
entering the classroom when they start
enforcing the Mandate it's disgusting
and when students aren't falling behind
in academics they're being indoctrinated
by sex and gender radicals
[Applause]
so yes I do dress up as Spider-Man
sometimes but it's the username this is
the only one that actually does make
sense because this is my daddy
the fact is if you live in a
democrat-run area your public schools
are in shambles they treat parents as
the enemies and far left activists as
the brave Heroes trying to thwart the
parents
so I'm going to make a prediction within
the decade there will be a huge Exodus
of Christian families from public
schools just going to happen
and another real issue versus all their
fakes the Young Thugs who are now
feeling empowered by Democrat policies
to go on racist Rampages and killing
sprees
no faking
for real oh my mama Kate how you think
I'm playing cat on for service
then there were two wannabe copycats
also in Memphis brazenly proclaiming
their own racist intent to kill a white
old lady while her grandkids are in the
car
so with the message of commit the crime
and do no time from George Soros back
DA's is it any shock that crime is out
of control in the United States of
course not
in the lefts all cops are bastards
message to young people see that
graffiti everywhere acab
let's put a Target on the back of law
enforcement so what's the result
a dangerous shortage of police officers
Across America and now of course crime
is creeping into the suburbs
and one of the toniest malls outside of
Washington DC and Tyson's corner of
Virginia yesterday Witnesses say gun and
Hammer wielding suspects waltzed into a
jewelry store smashed glass cases and
ran out with the jewelry a lot of
Rolexes apparently these Smash and grabs
have become an epidemic Across the
Nation
yo the cops are on the web man the cops
are on the way man it's cool hey get out
of the way get out of the way
foreign
I know
another real issue the Democrats are
actually making you poorer by the day so
your wages are lower now than they were
a year ago because of the cost of living
has gone up
so you may be working more than one job
just to pay the bills and inflation is
eating away at your money at your bottom
line
so just this week a Gallup poll revealed
that a majority of Americans now say
inflation is causing them personal
hardship
but Democrats don't care
and of course they never want you
focused on the very real issue of the
Biden foreign policy collapse
we're pouring billions of dollars into
Ukraine we're following Europe's lead on
energy and of course we see they're in
crisis mode right now
and do I even need to remind you about
what happened in Afghanistan of course
not
and we have zero China strategies
nothing that I can see
Democrats are just putting us on a path
to subservience to president XI and the
CCP
instead of us taking charge we're
begging them to talk to us
My Hope Is that President XI
will
recognize the benefit of getting both of
us moving in the same direction the
world needs to see
these two powerful countries actually
working together and there is no bigger
threat frankly on the planet right now
than the climate crisis
begging president G
now the choice isn't about choosing Maga
or anti-maga in November what it's about
is choosing truth or fiction
real or fake common sense or woke
fantasies
Democrats are guilty of almost every
malevolent act and goal that they
attribute to us
so every time the left tries to turn the
conversation to candidates like Dr Oz
droning on about his home in New Jersey
or maybe they try to get you to focus on
something controversial Blake Masters in
Arizona posted years ago
just to understand what the Democrats
are doing
distraction
the choice is obvious
either your lives are going to get
better by electing Republicans
or your lives will continue to get worse
by keeping Democrats in charge
you want to know how things will be here
after an entire election where Democrats
keep control we'll look no further than
to how California is doing
remember they had a chance to recall
Gavin Newsom the governor but they
didn't and now
it's blackouts crime and more Sanctuary
policies for illegals
oh and don't forget getting rid of gas
powered cars
so good luck getting to your two jobs
and an electric car that you can't
charge because of rolling blackouts
the left knows they can't debate
populist conservatives on policy because
we win a fair debate every time
so all they're left with is the politics
of distortion distraction and
demonization
they can raise money from plutocrats who
don't want change and then use their
regime media foot soldiers to
relentlessly enforce The Narrative of
their choosing
but we we can appeal to real people on
the real issues and eventually real
Stomps fake and that's the angle hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else